oh look at you junior detective
these Disney deleted scenes are
downright scandalous it's no wonder
these controversial scenes were removed
from our favorite Animated Classics wait
until you see the last one it's
everything you wouldn't expect from a
Disney movie
check out these deleted scenes Disney
does not want you to know about it's our
only chance
Toy Story 2 in the wake of the me2
movement there are many scenes from
older films that just did not age well
one such scene in the gag grill at the
end of Toy Story 2 the scene which was
played at the end of the movie during
the credits is free print worthy
it shows stinky feet in his box flirting
with a pair of Barbie dolls he pulls a
total creeper move telling the dolls
like you know I'm sure I could get you a
part in Toy Story 3 then he touches
Barbies hand cementing his creepiness
yeah good call on cutting this one out
Disney evil Elsa most fans know that in
the original concept for frozen Elsa was
going to be the villain there were a few
scenes from the original evil Elsa
storyline that were downright disturbing
one scene in particular made it all the
way to the storyboard process it shows
Elsa interrogating a couple of soldiers
from arendelle on her sister's
whereabouts she aggressively uses her
ice powers to torture the four guards
why are you on my Mountain which doesn't
exactly send the right message to kids
luckily they revamped the whole story to
the one we all enjoy today the Black
Cauldron the Black Cauldron it's
particularly dark especially for a
Disney movie but there is one scene that
was just too scary to show young viewers
it shows these spooky undead soldiers
whose flesh is boiling and melting off
their bones that would give Disney's
young fans nightmares for sure we're not
sure what the animators were thinking
with that horrific scene
after all it's supposed to be a kids
movie Mulan this scene was so terrible
that not only has it been deleted from
the film but there is no trace of its
footage anywhere on the Internet
it's a scene in which Shan Yu and his
army raid a village he orders them to
eliminate every villager including the
pets what if his soldiers tries to hide
a canary in his coat but Shan Yu catches
him feeds the canary to his Hawk and
introduces the soldier to the pointy end
of his sword
that's totally ruthless your walls and
armies have fallen it makes sense that
Disney decided to make that scene vanish
Aladdin do you guys remember the opening
song from the animated version of
Disney's Aladdin well it turns out the
lyrics used to be very different and
pretty racist too the song is about the
fictional Arabian city of Agrabah the
original song lyrics were it's a faraway
place where they cut off your ear if
they don't like your face
it's barbaric but hey it's home clearly
this paints a very negative picture of
the Middle Eastern people so they change
the lyrics to where it's flat and
immense and the heat is intense but they
left the barbaric line in there the new
live-action version of Aladdin took the
fix a step further I could just make you
a prince
now Will Smith sings the lines where you
wonder among every culture and tongue
it's chaotic but hey it's home there you
go Disney it only took you 27 years to
get it right but hey you did it
Tarzan we all know that Tarzan's parents
became Jaguar food at the beginning of
the movie Tarzan
we mean him an orphan in the jungle
thankfully this team happened off screen
however it almost didn't go down that
way there is a seriously disturbing WD
showing sabor the Jaguar dragging the
father's wounded baby away from a crying
baby Tarzan yikes thankfully Disney
pulled the scene and left that part to
the imagination
Fantasia one shocking scene in Disney's
Fantasia had to be cut due to some
seriously bigoted images they actually
animated a centaur with a painted black
face for the sunflower scene in the
original movie the little black centaur
is waiting on a bigger centaur who has
white skin and blond hair
the studio ultimately cut the scene due
to the stereotypical depictions of
African Americans from that era Disney
probably wishes they could bury that
controversial scene forever Beauty and
the Beast
okay this one is a bit less scandalous
but still worth noting in the original
animated classic Beauty and the Beast
there was going to be an 11-minute song
in the middle of the film the song was
called human again and it would have
played during the halfway point of the
film it was a Walt e-type song that
Lumiere and his friends sing about
wishing to be transformed back into
their original human form the filmmakers
decided that the song dragged on way too
long and just cut the whole thing danby
we all cried when bambi lost his mother
and the unforgettable scene in the
meadow but the original version of that
scene was even more gruesome and
depressing the deleted scene showed
Bambi finding his mother's impression in
the snow then he sees a hunter dragging
his mother away the studio decided the
best scene was too lengthy and
unnecessary so they gave it the ax
Zootopia Zootopia almost had some very
dark scenes depicting his beloved
characters in shock collars they
originally were going to go with the
story that when a young predator reaches
a certain age he is fitted with a shock
collar to curb any aggressive or excited
behavior thankfully Disney decided this
would be way too intense for young
viewers and scrapped the idea of the
shock collars that would have been super
disheartening to watch so they went with
milder forms of prejudice and oppression
in the film instead you know if I wanted
to avoid surveillance because I was
doing something illegal which I never
have which Disney deleted scene did you
find to be the most controversial let us
know in the comments if you love all
things Disney be sure to subscribe to
the things and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching bye
[Music]